i really
love
color
i notice it everywhere and in everything
my family makes fun of me
because i like to use colors with
elusive sounding names
like
celadon
a crew
carmine
now if you haven't noticed
i am black thank you
and when you grow up in a segregated
city as i have like chicago
you're conditioned to believe
that color and race
can never be separate
there's hardly a day that goes by
that somebody is not reminding you
of your color
racism
is my city's vivid hue
now we can all agree that
race is a socially
uh constructed phenomenon but it's often
hard to see it in our everyday existence
its pervasiveness is everywhere
the neighborhoods i grew up in were
filled with a kind of culturally coated
beauty
major commercial corridors were lined
with brightly painted storefronts that
competed for black consumer dollars the
visual mashups of corner stores and
beauty supply houses currency exchanges
are where i actually inadvertently
learned
the foundational principles of something
i would later come to know is called
color theory
i can remember being pretty intimidated
by this term in college
color theory
all these stuffy old white guys with
their treaties and
obscure terminologies
i've mastered each one of their colored
palettes and associated principles
color theory essentially boils down to
the art and science of using color to
form
compositions and spaces it's not so
complicated
this was my bible in college
joseph albers
posited a theory
about the color red
and it always has stuck with me
he argues
that
the iconic color of a cola can
is red and that in fact all of us can
agree that it's red but the kinds of
reds that we imagine are as varied as
the number of people in this room
so imagine that this color that we've
all been taught since kindergarten is
primary red yellow blue
in fact is not primary is not
irreducible is not objective but quite
subjective
what
alberts called this relational
relational
and so it was the first time that i was
able to see
my own neighborhood as a relational
context
each color
is affected by its neighbor
each
other is affected by its neighbor
in the
1930s the the united states government
created the federal housing
administration which in turn created a
series of maps
which were using a color coding system
to determine
which neighborhoods should and should
not receive federal housing loans
their residential security map was its
own kind of color palette and in fact
was more influential
than all of those color palettes that i
had been studying in college combined
banks would not lend to people who lived
in neighborhoods like mine that's me in
d86 their cartographers were literally
coloring in these maps and labeling that
color hazardous
red was the new black
and black neighborhoods were colored
the problem persists today and we've
seen it most recently in the foreclosure
crisis
in chicago this is best symbolized by
these exes that are emblazoned on the
fronts of vacated houses on the south
and west side
the reality is
that someone else's color palettes were
determining my physical
and artistic existence
ridiculous
i decided that i create my own color
palette and speak to the people who live
where i do
and alter the way that color had been
defined for us
it was a palette that i didn't have to
search far for and look for in the
treaties because i already knew it
what kind of painter
emerges from this reality
what color is urban
what color is ghetto
what color is privilege
what color is gang related
what color is gentrification
what color is freddy gray
what color is mike brown
finally
i found a way
to connect my racialized understanding
of color with my theoretical
understanding of color
and i gave birth to my third baby
colored theory
color theory was a two-year artistic
project in which i applied my own color
palette to my own neighborhoods in my
own way
now if i walk down 79th street right now
and i asked 50 people
for the
name of a slightly
greenish shade of cyan
they would look at me sideways
but if i say what color is ultra sheen
oh a smile emerges stories about their
grandmother's bathroom ensued
i mean who needs turquoise when you have
ultra sheen
who needs teal when you have ultra sheen
who needs ultramarine
when you have
ultra sheen
this is exactly how i derive my palette
i would ask friends
and family and people with backgrounds
that were similar to mine for those
stories and memories the stories weren't
always happy
but the colors always resonated more
than the product itself
i took those theories to the street
ultra sheen
pink oil moisturizer
if you're from chicago harold's chicken
shack
currency exchange
and safe passage
flaming red hots
loose squares
and crown royal bag
i painted soon to be demolished homes in
a much maligned area called inglewood
we gather up as much paint as i could
fit in my trunk
i call my most trusted art homies
my amazing husband always by my side
and we'd paint every inch of the
exteriors in monochromatic fashion
i wanted to understand scale in a way
that i hadn't before i wanted to to
apply the colors to the biggest canvas i
could imagine
houses
so i'd obsessively drive up and down
familiar streets that i'd grown up on
i'd cross-reference these houses with
the city's data portal to make sure that
they've been tagged for demolition
unsalvageable
left for dead
i really wanted to understand what it
meant to just let color rule to trust my
instincts to stop asking for permission
no meetings with city officials no
community buy-in
just let color rule
in my desire to paint different pictures
about the south side
these houses sit in stark contrast
to their
fully lined counterparts
we'd paint
to make them stand out like monopoly
pieces
in these environments
and we'd go
on these early sunday mornings and keep
going until we ran out of that paint
or until someone complained
hey
did you paint that
a driver asked as i was taking this
image one day
me nervously
yes
his face changed
oh i thought prince was coming
he had grown up on this block and so you
can imagine when he drove past and saw
one of its last remaining houses
mysteriously changed colors overnight
it was clearly not a crown royal bag
involved it was a secret beacon from
prince
and though that block was almost all but
erased
it was the idea
that prince could pop up in unexpected
places and give free concerts in areas
that the music industry and society had
deemed were not valuable anymore
for him
the idea that just the image of this
house was enough
to bring prince there
meant that it was possible
in that moment
that little patch of eggleston
had become synonymous with royalty
and for however briefly
eric bennett's neighborhood had regained
its value
so we traded stories despite being
strangers about which high school we've
gone to and where we'd grown up and mrs
so-and-so's candy store
of being kids on the south side
and once i revealed that in fact this
project had absolutely nothing to do
with prince
eric nodded and seeming agreement and as
we parted ways and he drove off he said
but he could still come
he had assumed full ownership of this
project and was not willing to
relinquish it even to me
its author that for me was success
i wish i could tell you
that this project transformed the
neighborhood all the indices that we
like to rely on increase jobs reduce
crime
no alcoholism
but in fact it's more great than that
colored theory catalyzed new
conversations about the value of
blackness color theory
made unmistakably visible
the
uncomfortable questions that
institutions and governments have to ask
themselves about why they do what they
do
they ask equally difficult questions of
myself and my neighborhood counterparts
about our value systems and what our
path to collective agency needs to be
color
gave me freedom in a way that didn't
wait for permission or affirmation or
inclusion
color
was something that i could rule now
one of the neighborhood
members and paint crew members said it
best when he said
this didn't change the neighborhood it
changed people's perceptions about
what's possible for their neighborhood
in big and small ways
pastors by would ask me why are you
painting that house when you know the
city is just going to come and tear it
down
at the time i had no idea
i just knew that i had to do something i
would give anything
to better understand color as both a
medium
and as an inescapable way that i am
identified in society
if i have any hope of making the world
better
i have to love and leverage
both of these ways that i'm understood
and therein lies the value
and the hue
thank you
[Music]